so these are three hard x.x to follow
especially Stephanie who I have heard
talk before but I think she brings
really to life literally so much of what
all of the rest of us are trying to work
with and study and understand but I also
want to thank George very very much for
really i think outstanding presentation
and i feel very grateful to you George
that you were able and willing to come
and participate in this event and Zoe
too i think is one of the most exciting
young people I've worked with in a long
time so thank you so much for a
wonderful talk and I also want to thank
all of you for coming tonight to help us
celebrate the launch of what I think is
the first-ever Center for complicated
grief certainly the first-ever
university-based center for complicated
grief the center would never have been
established without the strong support
and dedicated efforts of Dean Nakamura
and her wonderful administrative team
here at the school of social work also
our center activities are possible only
because of the contributions of a very
long list of people who provided a great
deal of different kinds of input and I
could just spend the rest of the time
that I'm going to talk to you listing
them all so I decided to I didn't want
to like not mention them but I'm
limiting the list to a few of the people
who have played an especially important
role first of all I want to mention
Nicole Anderson who's taken on the full
range of activities administrative
activities that are central to every
aspect of our functioning Bevan Campbell
has a leadership role in our new train
the trainer's program Natalya squirts
kiya has provided support
input throughout all phases of the
center development Nicole Alston is our
community liaison and her contributions
have been very very critical and
stephanie has been a consultant to us
and a very dedicated member of our team
and companion as we've developed this
Center additionally the intellectual
roots of this effort are planted very
firmly in the developmental
psychobiology laboratory of Myron hofer
who were very fortunate to have here
this evening who I first met in the late
1970s along with Harry share and Susan
Brunelli when I worked with them under
an n IM ht-32 fellowship in Myron's lab
important intellectual nourishment also
came from griefers researchers like
George who I met at least amet i think
when i first started this work and whose
work has always been very very important
to my own thinking but also a number of
other people a few of them include Paula
Clayton Sydney zouk Robert niemeyer and
Holly Pregerson none of whom are here
tonight and clinical researchers aetna
FOA Ellen Frank David kupfer Charles
Reynolds and Naomi Simon none of whom
are here tonight and biostatistical
colleagues Philip lavori Joel greenhouse
nigh wadhwan Melanie wall and you enjoy
Wang and lastly I would not have come to
the school of social work at all if it
weren't for the imagination
encouragement and support of my close
friend and Kaplan who you will hear from
shortly again there are many many others
who deserve mention but time doesn't
permit me to review the whole list of
people to whom the center owes its
existence because I do want to tell you
a little bit about what we're doing why
do we need Center for complicated grief
and you've heard a little bit about that
already
but I'll tell you my perspective so loss
as we've been saying is a natural part
of life that affects us I think in a
manner somewhat similar somewhat
analogous really to the way that injury
or illness does it disrupts our usual
functioning and it also triggers a
natural healing process George as he
pointed out and others have taught us
that for most people the disruption is
actually not so great and or we heal in
a natural environment with support from
friends and family without any kind of
clinical intervention healing after loss
means comprehending its finality
understanding all that it means that a
loved one is no longer in our lives and
being able to envision a future that has
purpose and meaning and the possibility
for joy and satisfaction even though
this person is gone most of us do heal
this way but some don't so over the past
three decades we've learned that we can
reliably identify a subgroup of about
ten percent of briefed people for whom
the natural healing process is derailed
as Stephanie so eloquently described and
this is the problem we call complicated
grief just to be clear about it we use
the term complicated not in the ordinary
sense of the word but in the medical
sense which refers to a superimposed
process that interferes with the natural
healing of another condition in this
case bereavement so my research group
has been working since the mid-1990s to
develop and test methods for recognizing
understanding and treating the
complicating processes in order to
permit natural healing to take over
there's a pressing need to help people
with complicated grief using the most
recent epidemiologic estimates
they're about there there are about 10
million people ten million individuals
in the United States alone who are
suffering in this way so Stephanie is
certainly not alone in 2009 my colleague
nie wadhwan developed a guesstimate he
called it of the rates and consequences
of untreated CG that turned out to fit
reasonably well with subsequent
epidemiologic findings according to
nawaz guesstimate cg costs our country
about 35 billion dollars each year in
lost productivity and accounts for about
five percent of currently unemployed
people importantly to the lives of
friends and loved ones are often very
impacted by a person with this problem
especially again as Stephanie pointed
out their children's lives CG has been
associated with medical illness
including cardiovascular illness and
cancer and with suicidality so given its
prevalence and impact we set out to tell
it to develop methods and tools to
facilitate clinical work with people
suffering from cg we constructed
invalidated screening instruments
structured diagnostic interview
cognitive and behavioral assessment
scales in a collection of forms and
handouts for use in a manualized 616
session treatment that's been efficacy
tested and that Stephanie told you a
little about our treatment approach is
based upon an attachment theory model of
bereavement that directs attention to
brain circuitry known to be involved in
close relationships as Zoe pointed out
the model posits the healing after loss
entails learning and emotion regulation
in a process that includes coping with
both loss and restoration related
problems in tandem and that proceeds
most effectively in the context of
strong supportive companionship
the treatment comprises a set of
well-developed procedures individualized
to fit the needs of each person the
treatment is structured because we
believe structure is helpful to people
being assaulted by strong emotions and
it utilizes some simple
psychotherapeutic principles that track
through the 16 sessions these include an
emphasis on self observation and
reflection the use of imagery which
fosters implicit learning especially
fosters implicit learning and
facilitates emotion activation and
encouragement of positive emotions which
can nurture creativity and
problem-solving signature techniques in
this treatment are imaginal revisiting
imaginal conversation with the deceased
person situational revisiting personal
aspirations and goals work work with
memories and pictures and meeting with a
significant other we've been funded by
the NIH for three different randomized
controlled trials of this treatment one
of which was completed and published in
2005 a second that is just ended
recruitment and a third that is ongoing
our first study documented cgt efficacy
in a dissertation study by Kim Glickman
a PhD candidate here at the school of
social work who couldn't be here with us
tonight has identified likely mediators
of its effectiveness the dissertation of
Angela Jeff Squire who is here with us
tonight a recent and a recent Columbia
doctor'll graduate focused on help
seeking and confirm the fact that
dissemination of our clinical materials
and information is the critical next
step in our work so the mission of the
center for complicated grief is simple
we want to improve the lives of people
suffering with this condition how are we
going to do this
our primary objective is as I've said I
think dissemination of knowledge the
center has established partnerships with
colleagues at Columbia some of whom
you've heard from this evening others in
New York City elsewhere in the United
States and globally in order to share
information trained clinicians and
support innovative research we've begun
programs that we hope will raise
awareness of CG in the population at
large we seek to reach CG sufferers as
well as their friends family members and
colleagues we hope to make widely
available our CG related assessment and
therapeutic tools and methods so that
clinicians in health and mental health
settings can make use of these
effectively we're beginning a project to
revamp our existing website in order to
utilize web-based and social media tools
to disseminate information as widely and
as effectively as possible we've begun a
year-long train the trainer's program
that will produce experienced clinicians
who can teach others there are local
participants in this project in this
program as well as individuals from
California Boston and Pennsylvania and
from italy ireland canada and china
we're working to develop and test
curricula for graduate postmasters and
postdoctoral education of mental health
professionals we're developing methods
to provide consultation and support for
researchers doing clinical research and
we're hoping to be able to develop seed
money research program to stimulate
innovative projects from young
investigators like Zoe death and loss
are weighty topics ones that most of us
naturally shy away from sometimes when I
tell my friends I work to help people
who have lost loved ones and are
struggling with intense unrelenting
grief they change the subject or they
tell me they don't have much interest in
this topic that is until they experience
it
partly as a result of this aversion many
are caught off guard when they lose a
loved one including some of the most
introspective deep thinking and creative
people in our culture people like Joan
Didion Megan O'Rourke and joyce carol
oates a basic assumption of our Center
and one that provides a guiding
framework for our activities is that
grief is a community affair Megan
O'Rourke has a simple elegant way of
saying this as she has up saying most
things she writes I believe in the
importance of individuality but in the
midst of grief i also find myself
wanting connection wanting to be
reminded that the sadness i feel is not
just mine but ours when we in the
helping professions adopt this
perspective and open our eyes to the
problems of death and loss and grief we
can provide a great and needed service
and simultaneously deepen our own
humanity and sense of community it is in
this spirit of community that we are
here tonight celebrating the launch of
the Center for complicated grief and the
reason why the center belongs here at
Columbia University School of Social
Work thank
you